là où ça bouge avec beaucoup d'à non ça
vaut faire ce soir avant les fêtes de
noël
mais pour l'instant retrouvons sabine
daniel et bertrand goulet au bord de
l'eau à grandcamp-maisy pour une
exposition assez original là où ça bouge
à grandcamp-maisy parce que l'art peut
venir de la mer et j'attends d'eux
contenaires qu'on doit me vrai avec des
oeuvres de dans l'idée en fait cette
favoriser la rencontre avec
le grand public et les artistes en fête
qu'on puisse effectivement se promenant
un dimanche tombé sur une exposition
sans avoir à pousser
la porte d'une galerie ou d'amuser en
fait c'est de se mettre l'art dans
l'espace public alors à l'intérieur deux
premiers containers le grand compte et
inviterait vous avez une peinture de jeu
et du goût qui fait partie d'une
collection de peintures qu'on a imaginé
entre 2004 et 2009 donc une collection
de 24 peinture et dans le second
conteneurs il ya des tapis nature d'un
artiste italien qui s'appelle piero
gilardi qui a fait une correspondance en
fait avec un artiste avec lequel on
travaille dans le quartier de la
guérinière s'appelle et manioc plus
grand donc le résultat de cette
correspondance est dans le conteneur à
grandcamp-maisy les deux conteneurs de
l'umih quand été accueillis par
l'association artistique locale la
repreneuse
alors on a beaucoup de retours puisque
moi j'habite là donc je vis là au
quotidien
je connais chaque habitant l'art
polonais assez présente l'association
est très présente et donc du coup les
gens viennent nous voir et ça pose
beaucoup de questions donc on répond aux
questions on a un échange et c'est assez
bien c'est non il vous reste jusqu'à
quand alors les les deux conteneurs on a
la chance d avoir jusqu'à à peu près on
va dire mi janvier les deux premiers
conteneurs artistiques sont donc en
créer un grand camp masi pour quelques
semaines encore
venez voir et fait les curieux c'est
juste en face de l'école de voile
merci sabine retour la fermeture éclair
de caen dimanche 20 décembre à partir de
midi une grande fête populaire avec de
la musique des groupes qu'est ce qu'on
va pouvoir écouter comme musique
alors on va commencer par manger en
musique avec les gigolettes ensuite ce
sera la guinguette squelette et puis on
finit le repas avec le choeur entier et
ensuite on vire toutes les tables et on
danse au son du bus mazette
et ensuite le soul vintage orchestra 5
euros l'entrée 5 euros pour tout l'après
midi voilà vous venez en famille vous
venez à partir de midi vous amenez votre
manger mais il ya des frites aussi c'est
ça
absolument oui de très bonnes frites de
très bonne facture et sabine marcy j'ai
amené mes frites verrait bien un bonnet
il se dit assez bien voilà c'est pour le
noël frites mais c'est quoi ça sert
c'est tout à fait ça non nous on fait
des vraies frites de ne pas au kit la
fermeture éclair pour quelques instants
lie à d'autres annonces à vous faire au
théâtre de corps du nouveau cirque en
provenance du vietnam avec à olemps faut
un spectacle illustrant la
transformation de l'homme rural du 29
décembre au 1er janvier
les soirées ou d'achat aux ateliers art
plume à salo sept groupes et dj sur deux
soirées dans une salle décorée par les
plasticiens du collectif c'est demain
samedi
la nova alençon sera elle aussi redécoré
version intersidéral pour accueillir le
5e festival des musiques électroniques
elle est trop les eaux c'est également
demain et samedi amateurs de films
d'animation lancez-vous participer au
marathon du court métrage fait court
organisait à l'aigle par les hommes
fourmies c'est du 28 au 30 décembre au
centre culturel de thann 1 et puis plein
de concerts de noël dans la région avec
par exemple les free gospel d'avranches
son concert à barenton dimanche à 17
heures
mais aussi le petit choeur de l'orphéon
de bayeux en concert dans le bessin
samedi 18 heures en l'église de rubercy
et dimanche 16 heures en l'église de
montfiquet et bien d'autres encore vélo
tant de manques
si ça bouge c'est la boîte à
zygomatiques du groupe oliphant un
concert pour les enfants l'espace tandem
de caen dimanche à 18 heures voilà on a
fait toutes les annonces je pense qu'on
pouvait faire pour ces fêtes de noël
demain spéciale enfants avec stéphanie
lemaire et pauline la truite
on vous souhaite de très bonnes fêtes de
noël je crois qu'on élude et à noël j'ai
vos cadeaux partez pas sans vos cadeaux
que marc voilà ça me fait plaisir joyeux
noël à vous la ville devint bien 2 film
de fabien drujon guillaume le conquérant
la jeunesse de guillaume le conquérant
le berceau de la normandie on va être
édifié à partir du 1er janvier donc bien
bonnes fêtes affirmant connu partout en
normandie de dieppe au mont saint michel
après une sortie en mai dernier là on
peut le trouver partout et voilà c'est
l'histoire c'est l'histoire l'histoire
c'est que toi merci beaucoup bonne fête
le réel